Jim there's been so much rumor and
speculation so let's start with what we
know for sure Kim jong-un hasn't been
seen in public since April 11th where's
he been well I don't know and that's
what the world wants to know now is that
a possible indication that he has poor
health yes but but we have to underline
that we played this game before with him
and with previous leaders where we've
said oh he's disappeared for two weeks
he's disappeared for three weeks you
know it does that mean he might die
similarly with the supreme leader in
Iran there have been numerous rumors
about imminent demise that never came
true
but whether whether he's in trouble or
not whether he's in trouble or not in
some ways that this gives us and it
gives the world community and the policy
community a chance to think what happens
if this is true because if it were to be
true maybe it's not maybe it happens a
month from now maybe it happens six
months from now but given the conditions
we haven't been talking about what that
means for North Korean for the region
and so it gives us a chance to say oh my
gosh maybe we ought to think about this
Jim I understand that Kim jong-un has
also disappeared from public view before
back in 2014 he was absent from the
public eye for forty days so this isn't
unprecedented why such a speculation now
was it as fierce the last time around
well first of all it's a cottage
industry you know so and how could you
not speculate I mean it's natural for
people and people in the media to do
that but obviously there's there are
some other things going on you know I'm
not a doctor his physical appearance
does not suggest you know a healthy
lifestyle
let's just be honest and then in
addition you know it's a pandemic right
in North Korea what where does North
Korea live right next to the country
where the corona virus originated now
North Korea's denied that it has any
cases I find that hard to believe I'm
not saying he would
I have contracted it obviously Boris
Johnson did so you know do we have a
smoking gun here that something is awry
no should we expect that something will
happen tomorrow probably not but again I
want to emphasize because of the focus
on coven 19 which is totally appropriate
and all the things that means we haven't
been thinking about North Korea but at
North Korea if the leader dies in a
context in which there's a global
pandemic it's under sanctions and
entering a recession as China's economy
declines that's a big deal and we might
want to think about that before it
happens rather than after it happens
sure Jim we've talked now a little bit
about Kim Jones health so let me ask you
what is the state of North Korea's
health system what sort of treatment
could Kim jong-un expect in country well
I think it's mixed obviously he's gonna
get the best health care of anyone in
that country bar none and you know there
are as you referenced reports the
Chinese doctors have made their way but
the health care system in general is not
very good and in terms of public health
and so you know that there are a lot of
unknowns here and we don't know what
coronavirus is doing in North Korea but
if it did manage to enter that public
health system is not prepared to deal
with that and I've had reports from the
ground that suggests that because the
North Koreans are essentially shutting
everything down there really aren't a
lot of international doctors
international medical aid workers in
North Korea to help with that and so you
know they're what 15 Europeans another
dozen UN officials not a lot of folks to
help the North Koreans deal with this so
you know whether it's its own health
problems maybe he has no health problems
at all but I think this bears watching
because it could lead to economic and
social instability in the country that
doesn't have nuclear weapons and feels
like we're threatening them so maybe we
should pay attention to that and we
absolutely will continue paying
attention to that Jim Walsh a senior
research associate and
from MIT thank you for joining us on al
Jazeera